in its formal submission to the office
of the prosecutor at the international
criminal court Al Jazeera included a
dossier of evidence that its lawyers say
cannot be ignored the submission to the
ICC prosecutor has highlighted the new
witness evidence and video footage which
clearly shows that Shireen and her
colleagues were directly fired at by
Israeli Defense Forces
the evidence they say undermines
Israel's claim that journalist Shireen
Abu akle was shot and killed by accident
caught in crossfire between Israeli
soldiers and Palestinians the lawyers
say it leaves no doubt there was no
Palestinian gunfire Shireen and her
colleagues were clearly identifiable as
journalists going about their work in
the occupied West Bank City of Janine
when they came under direct Israeli
gunfires
the dossier is comprehensive the
evidence is compelling there's no reason
now why the investigation cannot be
undertaken by the ICC the witnesses who
we've located are readily available to
the prosecutor there or here in The
Hague
the crime scene can be investigated and
the whole picture can be put together
and if there's sufficient evidence that
we say the years then the perpetrators
can be charged Al jazeera's submission
to the ICC has sparked a furious
response from the Israeli government
this is an incident that has been
investigated deeply and confidentially I
suggest the officials and Al Jazeera go
and check what happens to journalists in
Iran there is no Army that behaves
morally like the IDF
a news conference at the Hague heard
from International media Representatives
who said shireen's killing was part of a
systematic attempt to silence
journalists voices that would continue
unless Justice was served also present
with shireen's niece Lina abuakle it's
in these moments where we rely on the
International Community and
international courts to investigate such
crimes so so there's accountability and
also to prevent future crimes like this
from going unpunished it's easy to
forget that among the often heated
political rhetoric is a family grieving
we didn't just lose a journalist we lost
a human we lost someone
who was part of our family and who was
my only aunt
there's been no response yet from the
ICC either to the Abu akla family's own
submission of evidence in September this
year or to Al jazeera's case presented
here early on Tuesday but such is the
accumulated weight of evidence the
broadcasters lawyers say that there can
be no reason for the court not to take
the next step and launch a full
investigation
Al Jazeera at The Hague